JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about using gradients
to compute tangent
planes to surfaces.
So I have an example of a
practice problem here for you.
So what I'd like
you to do in part
a is to use gradients to
find the tangent plane
to the surface z equals
x cubed plus 3x y squared
at the point (1, 2, 13).
And in part b, I'd like you
to do something similar, which
is to use gradients to find
the tangent line to the curve x
cubed plus 2xy plus y squared
equals 9 at the point (1, 2).
So why don't you
pause the video,
have a couple goes at those.
Come back and we can
work on them together.
So hopefully, you had some good
luck working on these problems.
Let's just take a look at them.
So for part a, you're
given a function
in the sort of usual form
that we use to graph it,
which is you're given z
equals a function of x and y.
But in order to apply this
gradient method, what we really
want is we want to
look at this surface
as if it were a level surface
of some function of three
variables.
So in order to do that,
what we want to do always
is to bring the x,
y and z all together
on the same side with
just a zero or a constant
on the other side.
So let me do that.
So I'm going to
rewrite the defining
equation of this
surface as 0 equals
x cubed plus 3x y
squared minus z,
and I'm going to define
this right-hand side to be
a new function w of x, y, z.
All right?
So if I call this thing w,
then our surface in question
is just a level surface of w.
It's the level
surface w equals 0.
And so we know in that
situation that the gradient of w
is perpendicular to
its level surfaces.
It's orthogonal to
So the normal to our surface
is exactly the gradient of w.
All right?
So gradient of w is the
normal to our surface,
and a normal is what
we use to write down
the equation for
a tangent line--
oh, tangent plane, excuse me.
So, OK, so let's compute
the gradient of w.
Well, that's not hard to do.
We just take the
partial derivatives
with respect to x, y and z.
So the partial derivative
of w with respect
to x is 3 x squared
plus 3 y squared.
The partial derivative
with respect to y is 6xy,
and the partial derivative
with respect to z is minus 1.
So one thing to notice is
that when you do this method,
when you have the
function given at z,
surface given in the form
z as a function
of x and y, you're
going to bring the z over,
and you always have a minus 1
there when you set the
problem up this way.
Because you'll have
a minus z, and then
you'll just take the
partial with respect to z,
and the other terms will
only involve x and y,
so they'll be killed by
the partial derivative.
So in any case, this
is our gradient,
so we want the normal vector.
We were asked for the tangent
plane at a particular point,
I believe.
Yes, at the point (1, 2, 13).
So we need to
compute the gradient
at that particular point and
that will be our normal vector.
So the gradient at this point
is-- well, we just plug in,
so the gradient at (1, 2, 13).
So x is 1.
So this is 3 times
1 plus 3 times 4,
so that's going to be 15,
and 6xy is 12, and minus 1
is just minus 1.
So this is the gradient vector
at our point (1, 2, 13).
So now we have a point,
the point (1, 2, 13),
and we have the normal
vector 15, 12, minus 1,
so that gives us the equation
for the tangent plane right
off.
So the equation for
the tangent plane,
I just dot the normal
vector with the vector
connecting our point
to the point (x, y, z).
so that gives us 15 times--
well, our point is (1, 2, 3)--
so it's 15 times x minus 1
plus 12 times y minus 2 minus 1
times z minus 13 equals 0.
So in point-normal form, this
is the equation for that plane.
Great.
And if you wanted,
you could rewrite
this a whole bunch
of different ways,
but I'll just leave it there.
So let's do part b.
I guess I'll just start
it right below here.
So for part b, we have a curve
x cubed plus 2xy plus y squared
equals 9.
So this is a curve
that is defined
by this implicit
relationship between x and y.
All right?
And so what I want
to do is I can
do exactly the same process.
We're going to do
exactly the same thing.
We're going to find
the normal-point form
for the tangent
line, and so we're
going to do that by defining
a function f of x, y.
In this case, it's a function
of just two variables,
because we're only working
with a curve in two dimensions.
Before, we had a surface
in three dimensions,
so we had a function
of three variables.
So f of x, y, and
so then our curve
is exactly a level curve
of the graph of f, right?
It's the level curve f equals 9.
So in order to find
the tangent line,
I can do exactly the same thing.
I can find the gradient.
The gradient is normal
to the tangent line
and then I can use
normal-point form.
So the gradient of f is-- again,
f is just a polynomial function
so its gradient is
easy to compute.
It's 3 x squared plus
2y comma 2x plus 2y.
And so we're interested
in this tangent line
at a particular point.
So we're interested
at the point (1, 2).
So the gradient of f
at (1, 2), well, I just
plug in again, so
I get 3 plus 4.
That's 7.
And 2 plus 4 is 6.
And so again, the same analysis
as we used in the tangent plane
case works in the
tangent line case.
Let's come over here.
So (x, y) is on the tangent
line if and only if we have that
the gradient dot-- so that's
the gradient, [7, 6]--
dot the vector x
minus 1, y minus 2--
this is the vector
connecting the point (x,
y) to our point (1,
2)-- is equal to 0,
if and only if those two
things are orthogonal.
So this is-- i.e.
7 times x minus 1 plus 6
times y minus 2 is equal to 0.
So this is the point-normal form
for the equation of that line.
And again, you could,
you know, expand out
and rewrite this
in whichever forms
you happen to like to see
your equations of lines.
So there you go.
Using the gradient, we
can compute tangent planes
to surfaces.
Similarly, we can
use the same idea
to compute tangent
lines to curves.
The point is that the
gradient vector of a function
is orthogonal to the level
curves of that function.
And so we use that to
get the normal vectors
to our curves or our surfaces,
and with the normal vector,
we can then easily
compute the tangent plane
or the tangent line.
So I'll stop there.